Ce dont je veux parler c'est, en toile de fond
c'est de l'idée que les voitures sont de l'art.
C'est quelque chose qui a réellement du sens pour moi,
parce que les designers automobiles ont tendance à être relégués au pied de la pyramide,
nous ne faisons pas de livres de tables basses avec juste une lampe à l'intérieur,
et on ne pense aux voitures qu'en tant que produit
ce qui rend un peu difficile d'en approcher le côté esthétique
avec la même terminologie qu'on emploierait pour discuter d'art.
Et donc les voitures, en tant qu'art, s'inscrivent dans un contexte émotionnel -- si vous l'acceptez --
que vous devez appréhender de la même manière que vous le feriez avec l'art avec un grand A.
Maintenant vous allez voir une image de Michel-ange.
C'est complètement différent des automobiles.
Les automobiles sont des choses qui se déplacent seules, n'est-ce pas? Les ascenseurs sont des automobiles.
Et ils ne transmettent pas vraiment d'émotion, ils répondent à un besoin,
et effectivement les voitures existent depuis une centaine d'années
et ont rendu nos vies meilleures d'un point de vue fonctionnel de bien des manières,
elles ont aussi été une vraie source d'emmerdements.
Parce que les automobiles sont vraiment la chose qu'il nous faut résoudre.
Il nous faut résoudre la pollution, il nous faut résoudre les embouteillages --
mais ce n'est pas ce qui m'intéresse ici.
Ce qui m'intéresse dans ici c'est les voitures. Les automobiles sont peut-être ce que vous utilisez
mais les voitures sont ce que nous sommes, de bien des manières.
Et tant que nous pourrons résoudre le problème des voitures,
et je pense que nous le pouvons, avec les piles à combustible ou l'hydrogène, sujet qui séduit beaucoup BMW,
et beaucoup d'autres choses, alors je pense que nous pouvons regarder au-delà
et essayer de comprendre pourquoi tant d'entre nous sommes si accros
à la voiture -- et ce que ça signifie, ce que nous pouvons en apprendre.
Voilà où je veux en venir. Les voitures ne sont pas des costumes,
les voitures sont un avatar, les voitures sont une extension de vous-mêmes,
elles prennent vos pensées, vos idées, vos émotions et elles les multiplient --
votre colère ou encore autre chose. C'est un avatar.
C'est un super waldo et vous êtes à l'intérieur, et si vous vous sentez sexy,
la voiture est sexy. Et si la circulation vous enrage,
vous avez une "Chevy : tel un roc, " pas vrai?
Les voitures sont une sculpture - le saviez-vous?
Que chaque voiture que vous voyez là dehors est sculptée à la main.
Beaucoup de gens pensent, "Et bien, ce sont les ordinateurs,
et c'est fait par des machines et des trucs comme ça."
Et bien, elles le reproduisent, mais les originaux sont tous fait à la main.
C'est fait par des hommes et des femmes qui croient beaucoup dans leur métier.
Et ils mettent la même sorte de tensions dans la sculpture d'une voiture
que vous mettez dans une grande sculpture que vous iriez voir dans un musée.
Cette tensions entre le besoin d'exprimer, le besoin de découvrir,
et puis vous y mettez quelque chose de nouveau,
et en même temps vous avez les limites de l'art.
Des règles qui disent, voilà comment on traite les surfaces,
voilà ce que c'est que le contrôle, voici comment on montre qu'on maîtrise son art.
Et cette tension, cette découverte, qui poussent à quelque chose de nouveau --
et en même temps, ce sens d'obligation
envers l'artisanat --
c'est aussi fort pour les voitures que ça l'est pour n'importe quoi.
Nous travaillons avec de l'argile, ce qui n'a pas beaucoup changé
depuis que Michel-Ange a commencé à jouer avec,
et il y a une analogie très intéressante pour ça aussi.
Pour faire rapide -- Michel-Ange a un jour dit qu'il était là pour 'découvrir la silhouette à l'intérieur', vous voyez?
Nous y voilà, l'automobile.
Ce que vous avez vu, c'était 100 ans, vous vous en êtes rendu compte?
Entre celle-là et celle-ci, ça a beaucoup changé, non?
Bon, ce n'est pas du marketing, c'est un concept de voiture très intéressant ici
mais le côté marketing n'est pas ce dont je veux parler ici.
Je veux parler de ceci.
Qu'est ce ça veut dire que vous deviez laver votre voiture, de quoi s'agit-il, cette sensualité
qui fait que vous devez la toucher? Voilà la sculpture qui va dedans. Cette sensualité.
Et c'est fait par des hommes et des femmes qui travaillent comme ça, qui font des voitures.
Maintenant cette petite citation sur la sculpture de Henry Moore,
Je crois que cette "pression à l'intérieur" dont Moore parle -
au moins quand il s'agit de voitures -
ramène à cette idée de la moyenne.
C'est cette volonté de vivre, ce besoin de survivre, de s'exprimer,
qui vient dans une voiture, et s'empare de gens comme moi.
Et nous disons aux autres, «Faites ceci, faites ceci, faites cela», jusqu'à ce que cette chose prenne vie.
Nous sommes complètement infectés. Et la beauté peut être le résultat
de cette contagion, c'est tout à fait merveilleux.
Cette sculpture est, bien sûr, au cœur de tout cela,
et c'est vraiment ce qui met le savoir-faire dans nos voitures.
Et ce n'est pas vraiment très différent, quand ils travaillent comme ça,
ou lorsque quelqu'un travaille comme ça.
C'est ce même genre d'engagement, ce même genre de beauté.
Maintenant, j'en viens au fait. Je veux parler de voitures en tant qu'art.
L'art, au sens platonicien, c'est la vérité, la beauté, et l'amour.
Maintenant, c'est vraiment là que les designers de l'industrie automobile s'écartent des ingénieurs.
Parler d'amour ne pose pas vraiment de problème.
Parler de la vérité ou de la beauté ne nous pose pas vraiment de problème dans ce sens.
C'est ce que nous recherchons -
lorsque nous faisons notre métier, nous essayons vraiment de trouver cette vérité cachée.
Nous n'essayons pas de trouver la vanité et la beauté.
Nous essayons de trouver la beauté dans la vérité.
Cependant, les ingénieurs ont tendance à regarder les choses un peu plus selon Newton,
au lieu de cette approche quantique.
Nous avons affaire à des irrationalismes,
et nous avons affaire à des paradoxes dont nous admettons l'existence,
et les ingénieurs ont tendance à regarder les choses un peu plus peu comme
deux et deux font quatre, et si vous obtenez 4,0 c'est mieux, et 4,0000, c'est encore mieux.
Et cela conduit parfois à une certaine divergence
quant à savoir pourquoi nous faisons ce que nous faisons.
Nous avons à peu près accepté le fait, cependant,
que nous sommes les femmes dans l'organisation chez BMW -
BMW est une entreprise de type très viril, - les hommes, les hommes, les hommes, ce sont des ingénieurs.
Et nous sommes en quelque sorte le côté féminin. C'est d'accord,
c'est cool, tu la joues viril, nous allons être un peu plus féminines.
Parce que ce qui nous intéresse est de trouver la forme qui est plus qu'une simple fonction.
Ce qui nous intéresse c'est de trouver la beauté qui est plus qu'une simple esthétique,
c'est vraiment une vérité.
Et je pense que cette idée de l'âme, comme étant au cœur de superbes voitures,
est très valable. Vous le savez tous. Vous reconnaissez une voiture quand vous l'avez vue,
avec l'âme. Vous savez comment c'est fort.
Eh bien, cette expérience de l'amour, et l'expérience de la conception, selon moi,
sont interchangeables. Et maintenant j'en viens à mon histoire.
J'ai découvert quelque chose à propos de l'amour et du design au travers d'un projet appelé Deep Blue.
Et d'abord, vous devez venir avec moi pendant une seconde, et disons,
vous pouvez sortir le mot amour d'un tas de choses dans notre société,
le remplacer par le mot design, et ça marchera encore,
comme cette citation ici, vous savez. Ça fonctionne, vous savez?
Vous pouvez comprendre cela. Ça marche en truismes.
"Tout est juste dans le design et la guerre."
Certes, nous vivons dans une société compétitive.
Je pense que celui-là, il y a une chanson pop
qui décrit vraiment Philippe Starck pour moi, c'est comme
'puppy love' l'amour d'un chiot, c'est cool, non?
Brosse à dents, cool.
Ça ne devient grave que quand on regarde quelque chose comme ça. OK?
(Rires)
Il s'agit d'une substitution dont je crois
que chacun d'entre nous, dans la gestion du design, est coupable.
Et cette idée qu'il y a plus à aimer,
plus à designer, quand il s'agit de votre voisin, votre personne,
ça peut être physique comme ça, et peut-être que dans l'avenir, ça le sera.
Mais maintenant ce qui compte c'est de s'occuper des nôtres,
de nos propres équipes qui font la création. Donc, venons-en à mon histoire.
L'idée de gens au travail est ce avec quoi nous travaillons ici,
et je dois établir un lien avec mes designers lorsque nous créons des BMW.
Il nous faut une intimité partagée, une vision partagée
Cela signifie que nous devons travailler comme une seule famille,
nous devons nous comprendre de cette façon.
Il y a de bons moments, il y a des moments intéressants,
et il y a parfois un peu de stress aussi.
Vous voulez faire des voitures, vous devez sortir.
Vous devez faire des voitures sous la pluie, vous devez faire des voitures dans la neige.
C'est, soit dit en passant, une présentation que nous avons faite devant notre conseil d'administration.
Nous les avons trainés dans la neige aussi. Vous voulez connaitre les voitures à l'extérieur?
Eh bien, vous devez être dehors pour faire ça.
Et parce que ce sont des artistes, ils ont des tempéraments très artistiques.
Pas vrai? Maintenant une chose à propos de l'art, l'art c'est la découverte,
et l'art c'est vous découvrir vous-même à travers votre art. Vous voyez?
Et une chose à propos des voitures, c'est que nous sommes tous un peu comme Pygmalion,
nous sommes complètement amoureux de nos propres créations.
C'est un de mes tableaux préférés, il décrit vraiment notre relation avec les voitures.
C'est incroyablement écoeurant.
(Rires)
Mais de ce fait, l'intimité avec laquelle nous travaillons ensemble comme une équipe
prend une nouvelle dimension, un sens nouveau.
Nous avons un centre commun, nous avons tous un objectif commun,
que la voiture reste au centre de toutes nos relations.
Et c'est mon travail, dans le processus concurrentiel, de restreindre ça.
J'ai entendu aujourd'hui parler des gènes de mort de Joseph
qui doivent entrer et tuer la reproduction cellulaire.
Vous savez, c'est ce que je dois faire parfois.
Nous commençons avec 10 voitures, nous réduisons à cinq voitures,
à trois voitures, à deux voitures, à une voiture,
et je suis au milieu de cette mise à mort, au fond.
L'amour de quelqu'un, le bébé de quelqu'un.
C'est très difficile, et vous devez avoir un lien avec votre équipe
qui vous permet de faire cela, parce que leur vie tourne autour de ça aussi.
Ils ont ce gène infecté en eux aussi,
et ils veulent que cela vive, plus que toute autre chose.
Eh bien, ce projet, Deep Blue, m'a mis en contact avec mon équipe
d'une manière que je n'attendais pas, et je tiens à vous le transmettre,
parce que je veux que vous réfléchissiez à ça , peut-être dans vos propres relations.
Nous voulions faire une voiture qui soit un acte de foi complet pour BMW.
Nous voulions faire une équipe qui soit tellement éloignée de la façon dont nous l'avions fait,
que je n'avais qu'un numéro de téléphone qui me reliait à eux.
Donc, ce que nous avons fait au lieu d'avoir un groupe d'artistes qui soient vos exécutants,
nous avons décidé de libérer une équipe de designers et d'ingénieurs créatifs
pour savoir quel serait le successeur du phénomène SUV en Amérique.
C'est en 1996 que nous avons fait ce projet. Et nous les avons donc envoyés avec ce nom d'équipe,
Deep Blue. Maintenant, beaucoup de gens connaissent Deep Blue d'IBM,
nous leur avons volé le nom parce que nous avons pensé
que si quelqu'un lisait nos télécopies ils penseraient que nous parlions d'ordinateurs.
Il s'est avéré que c'était très futé parce que Deep Blue,
dans une entreprise comme BMW, a une accroche - Deep Blue, wow, cool comme nom.
Donc, les gens se sont investis. Et nous avons pris une équipe de designers,
et nous les avons envoyés en Amérique. Et nous leur avons donné un budget,
ce que nous pensions être un ensemble de choses à faire,
un calendrier, et rien d'autre.
Comme je l'ai dit, je n'avais qu'un numéro de téléphone qui me reliait à eux.
Et un groupe d'ingénieurs a travaillé en Allemagne,
et l'idée était qu'ils travaillent séparément
sur ce problème de ce qui succèderait au SUV,
ils se réuniraient, compareraient leurs notes. Ensuite, ils travailleraient séparément,
se réuniraient, et ils produiraient ensemble
un ensemble monumental de différentes opinions qui ne pollueraient pas les idées des uns et des autres -
mais en même temps, se réuniraient et résoudraient les problèmes.
En espérant qu'ils comprendaient vraiment le coeur du client,
là où le client est et vit avec eux en Amérique. Donc - on a envoyé l'équipe,
et en fait quelque chose de différent s'est produit. Ils sont allés ailleurs.
(Rires)
Ils ont disparu, très honnêtement, et tout ce que j'ai eu ce sont des cartes postales.
Maintenant, j'ai reçu des cartes postales des gars à Las Vegas,
et j'ai reçu des cartes postales des gars dans le Grand Canyon,
et j'ai reçu ces cartes postales des chutes du Niagara,
et rapidement, ils sont allés à New York, et je ne sais où encore.
Et je me dis, "Cela va être une super voiture,
ils font des recherches auxquelles je n'avais même jamais pensé avant. "
Vous voyez? Et ils ont décidé que, au lieu d'avoir un studio,
et six ou sept appartements,
il était moins coûteux de louer , l'ex-maison d'Elizabeth Taylor à Malibu.
Et - tout du moins, ils m'ont dit que c'était sa maison,
Je crois qu'une fois, elle y a fait une petite fête ou quelque chose comme ça.
Mais de toute façon, c'était la maison, et ils vivaient tous là-bas.
Maintenant, c'est 24 heures sur 24, 7 jours sur 7 de vie en commun, une demi-douzaine de gens qui avaient quitté leur -
certains avaient laissé leurs femmes et leurs familles derrière eux,
et ils ont littéralement vécu dans cette maison
pendant les six mois durant lesquels le projet a été en Amérique,
mais les trois premiers mois ont été les plus intenses.
Et l'une des jeunes femmes dans le projet,
c'était une dame fantastique, elle a en fait construit sa chambre dans la salle de bains.
La salle de bain était si grande, elle a construit le lit sur la baignoire -
c'est tout à fait fascinant.
D'autre part, je ne savais rien à ce sujet. OK?
Rien. Tout ça se déroule, et tout ce que je reçois ce sont des cartes postales
de ces gars à Las Vegas, ou d'ailleurs,
qui disent: «Ne vous inquiétez pas Chris, ce sera vraiment très bien." OK?
Donc, l'idée que j'avais de ce qu'est un studio de design était sans doute -
Je n'étais pas au courant de l'endroit où se trouvaient ces gens.
Cependant, les ingénieurs à Munich
avaient adopté une solution relevant de Newton,
et ils essayaient de trouver combien de porte-gobelets
peuvent danser sur la tête d'une épingle, et
ces questions vraiment graves auxquels le consommateur moderne est confronté.
Et on espérait que ces deux équipes se réuniraient,
et que cette collusion de créativité incroyable,
dans cet incroyable environnement,
et ces ingénieurs incroyablement stressés,
créerait des solutions incroyables.
Eh bien, ce que je ne savais pas, et ce que nous avons découvert c'était -
ces gars-là, ils ne peuvent même pas se parler dans ces conditions.
Vous obtenez une divergence entre pensées newtonienne et quantique à ce stade,
vous avez une scission si profonde et si avancée dans votre dialogue,
qu'ils ne peuvent pas mettre leur travail en commun du tout.
Et donc nous avons eu notre première réunion, au bout de trois mois, à Tiburon,
qui est à deux pas d'ici - vous connaissez Tiburon?
Et l'idée était qu'au bout des trois premiers mois de ces recherches indépendantes
ils présenteraient le tout à M. Goschel -
qui est maintenant mon patron, et à cette époque, était le co-mentor sur le projet -
et ils présenteraient leurs résultats.
Nous pourrions voir où nous allions,
nous verrions la première indication de ce qui pourrait être
le phénomène qui succèderait au SUV en Amérique.
Et j'avais donc ces idées dans ma tête, que ça allait être génial.
Je veux dire, je vais voir tant de travail, c'est si intense -
Je sais que probablement Las Vegas y était pour beaucoup,
et je ne suis pas vraiment sûr de ce qu'apportait le Grand Canyon -
mais de toute façon tout cela allait s'assembler,
et j'allais voir un produit vraiment super.
Donc nous sommes allés à Tiburon, après trois mois,
et l'équipe s'était réunie la semaine précédente,
plusieurs jours à l'avance.
Les ingénieurs étaient venus en avions, et les designers se sont réunis avec eux,
et ils ont préparé leur présentation ensemble.
Eh bien, il s'est avéré que les ingénieurs n'avaient rien fait.
Et ils n'avaient rien fait parce que -
comme dans l'industrie automobile, les ingénieurs sont là pour résoudre des problèmes,
et nous leur demandions de créer un problème.
Et les ingénieurs attendaient que les designeurs leur disent,
"Voici le problème que nous avons créé, maintenant aidez-nous à le résoudre."
Et ils ne pouvaient pas en parler. Donc ce qui s'est passé,
les ingénieurs se sont pointé avec rien.
Et les ingénieurs ont dit aux designers ,
"Si vous arrivez avec tous vos trucs, nous partons,
nous nous retirerons du projet. "
Donc, je ne savais rien de tout cela,
et nous avions une présentation qui avait un ordre du jour, et tout ça.
Il y avait beaucoup de dialogue.
Nous avons passé quatre heures à entendre parler du vocabulaire
qu'il faut construire entre les ingénieurs et les designers.
Et là, je m'attends à tout moment, "OK, on va tourner la page,
et je vais voir les voitures, je vais voir les croquis,
Je vais peut-être voir une idée de la direction où on va."
Le dialogue continue , avec des cartes mentales de mots, et bientôt
il est devenu évident que, au lieu d'être ébloui par la brillance,
j'ai été sérieusement dérouté par les conneries.
Et si vous pouvez imaginer à quoi ça ressemble,
d'avoir pendant des mois des indications par cartes postales de la super façon dont l'équipe travaille,
et ils sont là dehors à dépenser tout cet argent, et ils apprennent,
et ils font tous ces trucs.
J'ai pété les plombs, vous comprenez? Ça m'a rendu fou.
Vous vous souvenez probablement de Tiburon, ça ressemblait à ça.
Après quatre heures, je me suis levé et j'ai mis cette équipe en miette.
J'ai leur ai crié dessus, j'ai hurlé, «Qu'est-ce que vous fichez?
Vous me laisser tomber, vous êtes mes designers,
vous êtes censés être les créatifs,
bon sang, qu'est-ce qui se passe ici? "
C'était probablement une de mes meilleures tirades, j'en ai de bonnes,
mais ce fut probablement une de mes meilleurs. Et je leur suis rentré dedans;
comment pouvaient-ils prendre l'argent de BMW,
comment pouvaient-ils avoir des vacances pendant trois mois et ne rien produire, rien?
Parce que bien sûr, ils ne nous disaient pas qu'ils avaient trois breaks
plein de dessins, de modèles, de photos - tout ce que je voulais,
qu'ils avaient enfermés dans les voitures, parce qu'ils avaient manifesté leur solidarité avec les ingénieurs -
et ils avaient décidé de ne pas me montrer quoi que ce soit,
afin de donner à la résolution des problèmes une chance de commencer,
parce qu'ils ne s'étaient pas rendus compte, bien sûr,
qu'ils ne pouvaient pas créer de problème.
Donc nous sommes allés déjeuner -
(Rires)
Et je dois vous dire, ce fut un déjeuner sérieusement silencieux.
Les ingénieurs étaient tous assis à un bout de la table,
les designers et moi étions assis à l'autre bout de la table, très silencieux.
Et j'étais tellement furieux, furieux. OK?
Probablement parce qu'ils s'étaient bien amusés et moi pas, vous savez.
C'est ce qui rend furieux, pas vrai?
Et quelqu'un m'a demandé des nouvelles de Catherine, ma femme,
avait-elle pris l'avion avec moi ou quelque chose comme ça?
J'ai dit: «Non,» et ça m'a fait penser à ma femme.
Et je suis rappelé que lorsque Catherine et moi nous sommes mariés,
le prêtre a fait un sermon très plaisant, et il a dit quelque chose de très important.
Il a dit, "L'amour n'est pas égoïste,
L'amour ne signifie pas compter combien de fois je dit, 'Je t'aime."
Cela ne signifie pas que vous eu des rapports sexuels tant de fois ce mois-ci,
et que c'est deux fois moins que le mois dernier,
ce qui signifie que tu ne m'aimes pas autant.
L'amour n'est pas égoïste. "Et j'ai réfléchi à ça et je me suis dit,
«Vous savez, je ne fais pas preuve d'amour ici. Je ne montre vraiment pas d'amour.
Je suis incertain, je suis incertain et sans confiance.
Ce n'est pas possible. Ce ne peut pas être que j'attends un certain nombre de croquis,
et pour moi c'est ma méthode de quantification pour qualifier une équipe.
Cela ne peut pas être. "
Alors je leur ai raconté cette histoire. Je ai dit, "Les gars, je pense à quelque chose ici,
ça ne va pas. Je ne peux pas avoir une relation avec vous les gars
qui repose sur un postulat qui est quantifiable.
Basé sur un principe dicté qui dit: «Je suis un patron, vous faites ce que je dis, sans confiance."
J'ai dit: «Cela ne peut pas être."
En fait, nous avons tous éclaté en larmes, pour être honnête,
parce qu'ils ne pouvaient toujours pas me dire combien de frustration ils avaient accumulé
en eux, de ne pas pouvoir me montrer ce que je voulais,
et d'avoir simplement à me demander de leur faire confiance que cela viendrait.
Et je pense que nous nous sommes sentis beaucoup plus proches ce jour-là,
on a coupé un grand nombre de chaînes qui n'ont pas lieu d'être là,
et nous avons forgé le concept de ce que sont une vraie équipe et une vraie créativité.
Nous avons remis la voiture au centre de nos pensées, et nous avons bien remis l'amour,
je pense, au centre du processus.
Soit dit en passant, cette équipe a continué à créer six concepts différents
pour le prochain modèle de ce que serait la proposition
pour la génération qui succèderait aux SUV en Amérique.
Un de ces concepts était l'idée d'un coupé crossover -
vous le voyez en bas, le Coupé X - ils ont eu beaucoup de plaisir avec ça.
C'était l'interprétation de nos motos,
la GS, comme Carl Magnusson dit, "brute-iful",
de l'idée de ce que pourrait être une moto, si vous ajoutez deux roues de plus.
Et donc, en conclusion, la leçon que je voulais vous transmettre,
était celle-ci. Je vais aussi voler une petite citation tirée du «Petit Prince».
Il y a beaucoup à dire sur la confiance et l'amour,
si vous savez que ces deux mots sont synonymes de design.
J'ai eu une relation très, très significative avec mon équipe ce jour-là,
et c'est resté comme ça depuis.
Et j'espère que vous aussi vous trouvez que le design,
et l'art du design, c'est plus que de le faire vous-même.